remember this the journalists from
russian state tv who burst into a
broadcast with a banner saying they're
lying to you
well it's been a hard couple of months
for marina of sianakova
we're with her on route to her latest
court hearing for supposedly
discrediting russia's armed forces in an
interview two weeks ago
where she called the war the worst crime
of the 21st century
[Music]
this was two weeks ago outside the
kremlin after the attack on venezue her
sign calls putin a murderer
but she's still only facing a fine and
that's led to a host of conspiracy
theories
and all these rumors that you're
actually in the pay of the fsb and
that's why they're not coming down on
you harder are they true
absolutely
again
she bears up well under almost constant
harassment the cameras here aren't all
friendly
a lot of interest still in marina of
cianakova's case here in russia the
first question she was asked by her
former employers at state tv just now as
she went in was how is it to betray your
motherland
the court verdict is as expected a 50
thousand ruble fine that's around seven
hundred pounds though
is convinced that the state is biding
its time and will bring further
charges she cuts a lonely figure now
with no job or income fighting for
custody of her kids but still convinced
of her cause
diana magney sky news moscow